u.s. presidential elections are around
the corner a lot of people ask me same
pattern what do you think is going to be
the Democratic nominee to face off Trump
so today I'm gonna tell you a few
different things what I'm going to give
you the history of the last hundred
years
who won presidency what was the score
was there another candidate we're going
to talk about today's issue in the back
here on what matters when it comes on to
the debate and last but not least if I
was a campaign manager I got ten points
here on what it's going to take to win
2020 presidential election so let's get
right into it by the way this is going
to be probably the most technically
challenging election to win because the
moving parts today are way more than
they've ever been so strategically
winning this one is like winning a war
in ways and no country or nation has
ever had to face very technical to win
today's election but we'll cover that
let's let's go into the history books
okay from 1920 till today whose one
presidency and what are some events that
taking place obviously 2020 we don't
know yet we have president Trump as a
Republican nominee if he stays this way
and we have the Democratic nominee that
will find out who it's going to be
there's a lot of guys fighting for dough
we'll find out who it's gonna be 2016
Trump meets Hillary Clinton 306 to 232
then it's Romney Obama Obama wins 332 to
206 McCain Obama Obama wins 365 to 173
Kerry won against Bush jr. in 2004 286
to 251 Bush wins Bush jr. against Gore
very close one Nader was also competing
in this one you're looking at 271 to 266
one of the closest elections of all time
were Florida has to come out and figure
out and recount all this stuff anyways
Bush jr. ends up winning and beats Al
Gore 1996 Bob Dole against Clinton
Clinton wins bill 379 to 159 a landslide
and Bill Clinton also beat bush senior
four years prior to that 370 to 168 and
in that year 1992 there's an interview
done with George Bush Senior before he
passed away and the interviewer asked a
question about what are your thoughts
about Ross Perot it was the only
he didn't want to talk about because he
got upset when a named Roscoe was
mentioned because if Roz Pro doesn't run
in that election
odds are George Bush Senior would have
won again he was a former director CIA
decorated tap of a resume but Ross Perot
helped Bill Clinton become president
very interesting election then prior to
that I was senior against Dukakis
obviously a senior was two of four 26 to
111 it was interesting when Dukakis try
to go around and the tank and then
didn't look good military kind of people
started making fun of them and in one of
the cases during the debates somebody
asked them what would you do if somebody
you know was to rape your wife would you
want that person to get the death
penalty and instead of showing any kind
of emotion on what happened to his wife
he just went very logical and the
American people like this this guy have
a heart he just the person asks you to
question the debate that's your wife how
do you answer just like that like it's
normal you can't answer like that where
is your heart
and so that lost and the other tank
think heard him and the next thing you
know he lose it but he had a chance of
actually beating bush senior but ended
up changing due to debates and a couple
other things Reagan Mondale 525 213
landslide is what we're talking about
and then Reagan Carter also landslide
for 89 to 49 and then Ford against
Carter Carter one close race to 97 to
241 prior to that Nixon went against
McGovern 520 to 17 land slides second
biggest landslide based on what we're
talking about here third biggest lands
that we'll talk about here in a minute
why McGovern lost is a very interesting
story on what some of the guys the
nominees when it comes down to the real
debate this this decision one decision
hurt McGovern from the chances of
beating Nixon but it didn't happen Nixon
won against Humphrey beat amat 302 to
191 George Wallace was also in it but he
won that one in 1964 Goldwater went
against Lyndon Johnson and that one
obviously Goldwater lost as a Republican
LBJ won 46 to 52 and this was a time the
reason why it's a landslide is because
Goldwater didn't necessarily support
civil rights and and prior to that in
1960 african-americans voted 60% of
african-americans voted Democrat forty
percent voted Republican but after
Goldwater the next election for what he
did
it went from 64% to 92 percent of
African Americans voting Democrat
because they were not happy about a
Republican taking a position there so it
shifted the african-american vote to to
pretty much all Democratic because of
that one single event that takes place
Nixon JFK obviously JFK wins 303 to 219
this is very interesting because during
that time in 1950 in America when
elections were being shown on TV and
radio only 11 percent of Americans in
1950 had a TV one more time 1950 11
percent had a TV 1960 88 percent had a
TV so when in 1960 debate took place
between Nixon and John F Kennedy what
people didn't know is Nixon had just
come out of the hospital and he was sick
he was hospitalized for several days he
didn't shave he had a five o'clock shave
he looked totally tired and John F
Kennedy showed up tanned looking good
perfectly shaped nice suit 88% Americans
had TV to watch and said oh my gosh John
F Kennedy won but the interesting thing
part was that everybody that was
listening to the radio they said Nixon
won things changed against TV changed
the game JFK wins Eisenhower against
Stevenson 457 273 Eisenhower wins
back-to-back same candidates 442 1889
do against Truman 303 to 189 Truman wins
Dewey goes against FDR obviously FDR
wins
FDR beats Wilkie FDR beats Landon I mean
these are just landslides FDR be to burr
look at the score of what it was like
523 to 8 that is a landslide of
landslide it's the greatest landslide in
the last hundred years then he got
Hoover goes against Smith Hoover wins
and in Coolidge goes against Robert La
Follette and he wins and then last but
not least Harding goes against cows and
he wins as well 404 to 127 so when you
look at this couple things to think
about the yellows is when a president
the existing president runs for
re-election and they lose Bush Senior
lost Carter lost for re-election for
didn't ever get nominated for president
or vice president just so happens that
it was a tricky thing that happened that
he ended up becoming a president but
when he did run for re-election he lost
and then obviously Hoover losses one
when against when he
Str so when you're looking at this is
important to know history and events
that shift everything with politics you
got to realize a lot of things up here
that shift that has to do with social
media you know Trump had to do with
Twitter Obama had to do with Facebook
you know it had to do with YouTube a lot
changed there where people started
looking at the stuff now today's topics
you hear a lot of different things
that's being debated what could cause an
election to be won or lost what are the
topics that are people wanting to know
about people that are watching right now
I was at a place here the day guy asked
me a question saying Pat we're a minyan
Ville Yountville is by Napa Valley
Yountville won the fun fact is that's a
city that has more Michelin star
restaurants in Yountville than any other
city in the world because people with
money go to this place and it got comes
up and he says hey Pat so what do you
think's gonna happen with the economy
what do think is going to be taking
place I said there's so many moving
parts today more than my entire in my
generation I've never seen so many
different moving parts there's so many
things changing that you got almost pay
attention to the things that's going on
so here's a few things so five key
geopolitical issues that are trending
right now number one is power plays by
different countries what's gonna happen
China is trying to play power place us
Russia
we're talking about trade war sanctions
5ga I this is all taking place and even
right now conversations of China willing
to work with us and they're willing to
share the 5g technology they're going
back and forth all of this stuff I did a
video called the us-china trade war I
think ended up getting two and a half
three million views and one of the
things that I said is Trump's playing
the card of 5g with sanctions on China
with the hopes of China being able to
give the technology of 5g for us to be
able to do it and they weren't gonna
give it to us because a lot of 57
different countries apparently working
together but not the US but now China is
kind of starting to be open to because
the whole made in China 2025 plan to
become the largest most powerful Empire
in the world it's kind of shifted just
because the sanctions that we have so we
don't still know what's going to happen
here but it's definitely one of the
issues the second point is global
economic risk which is the market crash
that a lot of things depending with a
market crash I could definitely hurt
Trump because Trump is always using the
economy card so if it doesn't work for
President Trump that's gonna hurt him
obviously brexit EU Iran Iran is not
backing down I mean they're not sitting
there saying okay us let's find a way to
negotiate and the whole controversy is
well what just happened the Foreign
Minister if you haven't seen this
sit-down with CNN one of the
commentators on CNN sits down with the
foreign minister of Iran Mohammad Zarif
you should hear how he answers just the
first two minutes matter of fact I let's
put the link below very obvious he's not
being cocky arrogant he's just saying if
you want to go to war we're ready let's
good but we're not backing down so
rather than expecting them to say let's
sit down and negotiate they're not
willing to do that so that that could be
friction especially during a time like
this
point number three Saudi stresses and
global energy market obviously we know
what happened with Saudi recently where
they're blaming Iran Yemen who did it
we're not taking responsibility then how
did you get it stronger
you know drone like this to be able to
attack that's not possible to go
hundreds of miles people regular guys
can't have the kind of money to be able
to have a drone like that in Iran and
it's not us they said they did it we
don't want to investigate it and it's
again oil who's gonna have the power of
oil in the Middle East Iran Iraq Libya
terror attacks a lot of that is in the
same place and then for is an eventful
year for Latin America Mexico has a new
president who's somewhat like a Bernie
Sanders socialist Brazil has a new
president that somewhat a Donald Trump
capitalist he's changing the game over
there with capitalism Venezuela going
through what they're going through with
Maduro and they're still friction there
with oil so Latin America has a lot to
do with the election and then pending
word that anytime anything could take
place there's a lot of moving parts
right now President Trump is obviously
saying that he is very hesitant to go to
war a lot of people are saying we got to
go attack we got to go attack we got to
go attack he's kind of holding back
because he's he's never been for war if
there's one thing about him the last 30
years he's never been for war and he's
trying to avoid it from gone but we'll
see what's gonna be taking place so then
there's other issues immigration you
hear people talking about immigration
what are we going to do with this wall
what are we gonna do with you know
crimes and ice and the kids all these
things are topics that these candidates
are gonna talk about college debt the
Elizabeth Warren is talking about the
fact that she wants to help you know
kind of the 42 million students that
have the debt to wipe tears out but
Bernie Sanders going to a whole
different level saying I want to wipe
out 1.6 trillion
dollars and ruts write it up let's just
eliminate all of it so you know sounds
noble but can we afford it to say 1.6
street 3 is 6 trillion because is the
issue the debts that we write up or is
the issue colleges why are they charging
so much well that's why it's a cost so
much to go to school maybe it's not a
debt issue maybe it's a price issue that
colleges need to change their pricing
but that's gonna be coming up Medicare
for all you hear a lot of people saying
who raise your hand if you're Medicare
for all day raise their hands
automatically during a category when
they do that then you got the green New
Deal marijuana legalization it's not as
big as it was before because it's pretty
much being accepted by a lot of states
you bi is gonna come up it's one of the
reasons why angry Hank came up because
at least he came up saying this is my
plan he went from no one known who he is
a day before and then all of a sudden
everyone's saying Andrew yangyang gank
created a ton of momentum passed up by a
lot of people I think he's number four
right now as one of the candidates then
it's criminal justice cyber secured
Electoral College guns medication
military a lot of these that will come
up now here's my ideas when it's come
down to it when it's coming out to 2020
election if I'm looking at who's winning
today there's 10 things I'm gonna be
thinking about if I'm on the Democratic
side obviously under one face enough and
the easiest way to try to beat them as
may be the impeachment think but this
whole campaign of impeaching can
backfire so much because it backfired on
Republicans years ago and it hurt them
for a long time so if they do this this
whole impeachment process of meeting 2/3
of Senate while the Senate majority is
Republican to be able to beat the Senate
majority at a time like this you gotta
be able to control the house and it's
just not as easy as they're making it
out to be so I'm surprised quite frankly
myself that a Nancy Pelosi is going out
to being that public about being being
able to do something like this knowing
the results are you got to convince the
Senate two-thirds how are you gonna do
it you may be able to have it in place
but you can't you can't finalize it so
it's it's a move that the only time it
makes sense to go and propose
impeachment it's if you are certain you
have all of it in place and they don't
so it's a way too risky to do that but
let me give me a couple things impact
2020 election number one is matchup
let me explain to what I mean by matchup
in sports basketball if I am the best
team in the NBA and I have a
Center and I'm facing you if you don't
have somebody to match up with me and
I'm the best player you're gonna have a
hard time competing against me if I'm
the most dominant team in the league and
it's because of a big man and you don't
have nobody to face off against me
there's gotta be some kind of a matchup
there right so the matchups gonna be
Obama goes against McCain young McCain
has a bigger resume but people are like
I don't know I just
McCain doesn't excite me nice man good
resume see the video powr SPECT but
Obama gets up there and talks and smiles
and wife smart and both and man I just
feel good matchup favor Obama matchup
Bill Clinton Bush Senior bush senior you
know he's the typical guy that's you
know been in politics for so much and
been in CIA and man he's so like part of
the institution and he's part of the
swamp do you want somebody like that or
maybe you bring somebody like a Bill
Clinton who's young and vibrant and at
the time Hillary was like also pretty
powerful with matchup right and a
matchup was and it was also rosboroughs
I kind of helped out Reagan Carter oh my
gosh Reagan Dream America is the
greatest country in the world and
Carter's like well we are not the best
nation we got some work to do on it's
the matchup right so who's gonna match
up best with Trump watch this I wrote
out a chart here okay meaning far left
liberal far-right Republican let's put
the furthest right Ted Cruz right Ted
Cruz is pretty much conservative in
every policy you can think about
far-right conservative let's just say
Ted Cruz prior to that is Reagan right
in the middle of him and Trump Trump is
in my eyes not really a Republican I see
Trump more as an independent leaning
right it's really what he is like
certain issues that many Republicans
were like what are you talking about
you're okay with that yeah I'm okay it's
not even an issue I don't want to talk
about it so if we put Trump here and we
put bill glint Bill Clinton somewhat
left okay when he became a president he
wasn't far left this is why he was good
where a lot of people liked him - Monica
Lewinsky yes she wasn't a bad president
he was a good president and he was okay
with Newt Gingrich and I know some
people always comment so how could you
say he was a good president he was
willing to go across the aisle and say
Newt what do we want to do about this
and who's like let's this economy works
and then BOOM be kind
was doing really good Obama's probably
people thought Obama was way more
socialist he's not socialist he's
probably a little bit left and Bill
because he came out with the Obamacare
and then it's Warren to the left of
Obama and then it's Sanders to the left
of warrant so when you look at this and
say the Democratic Chairman or you know
campaign manager whoever it is that's
watching his DNC chairman is watching
this
he likes far left but today far left is
gonna lose the people in the middle
Trump won because a lot of people in the
middle said okay I can go this way okay
I'll go this way if they really want to
have somebody that can have a real match
up about him with him it can't be
somebody that's on the far left so we
have to keep up with the matchup to see
what's gonna take place there now again
they're gonna choose whoever you're
gonna choose because it's gonna be based
on who vote number to choosing the right
VP let me explain to what I mean by
right VP do you remember here when I
explained the story about Nixon and
McGovern why he lost five 22:17 here's
why McGovern when's the nominee he calls
all these guys to be his vice president
they all say no he makes the phone call
to Senator Eagleton who said Eagleton
who says yes and he becomes as VP right
he says I'll agree to do it because
McGovern wanted to win the Catholic vote
so he brings him in but he doesn't vet
the VP to find out what his background
is August 1st they announced that this
guy is gonna be the VP 18 days later he
drops out because three times he was
hospitalized for depression and two
times he went through electroshock
therapy two times and once they came out
they're like if you can't choose the
right VP how can you make the right
decisions as a president so whoever
becomes the nominee on the Democratic
side who are they gonna choose as a VP
very critical they got to do the proper
background and bedding from now if I'm
working for Warren Sanders Biden any
domain names
I'm already vetting everybody's
background right now to see what they
have and what they don't have I'm not
waiting till then and I'm kind of
starting to do the matchup to see what's
gonna be taking place next anti campaign
versus Pro campaign you've seen you've
seen a lot of people saying all I know
is when it comes down to the day of
voting for new president as long as
not president that's what matters okay
raw awesome
it may sound exciting but that campaign
doesn't win let me explain to you why it
doesn't win because anti doesn't
necessarily mean we know your plans or
org is all anti-trump anti-trump white
supremacist all this stuff nobody has
any clue what his plans are and he goes
and jeans picture and Vanity Fair and
look at me I'm so cool people gonna like
me my name is Beto I'm white but I can
talk Spanish and I'm like I'm trying to
connect with them but what are your
plans what are you gonna be doing if you
only campaign or on anti-trump you will
not win if it's only anti-trump there's
got to be a plan even Trump went up
there and says what make America great
again wall immigration here's what I'm
doing and you went and started preaching
it right you're seeing some people doing
that with their campaigns Elizabeth
Warren knows what she wants to do Bernie
you know what he wants to do Andrew yank
you know what he wants to do Joe Biden
you somewhat know we want he wants to do
you kind of know what he wants to do
those are the people that have their
ideas but if they go to a whole
anti-trump think it's gonna backfire on
them because typically history tells us
you don't win when you go on a tight
Rahm you've got to go policies next
economy for economy is very good right
now so if you try to go against the
economy you don't have a really good
argument people gonna say condom is
already doing good what are you gonna do
to the economy that's not already
happening right now so but they have to
be ready that if one of these stink hits
an economy shift they gotta have their
story prepared like it's like playing
football somebody's coming from this
side you got to have the blitz you got
to have the block and you got to have
the fullback you gotta have all that
stuff prepared before it happens so they
gotta be prepared in case now drops
three four or five thousand points what
is your argument gonna be now because
that's gonna change the game so number
five is focusing on areas of weakness
let me explain to what I mean by this so
if you took all these policies of Trump
see where his week go there that matters
to the American people for instance if
you go to marijuana and that's what
you're gonna focus on but American
people are already saying listen man I
got it I'm good you know marijuana it's
fine it's okay it's not really gonna get
that kind of traction it's gotta be one
of these issues that matters the most to
the people that's gonna get traction or
you cream
like Andrew yang created UB I never
thought about this hey ice come in if it
comes it's gonna take jobs were going to
lose trillions of dollars of jobs we
need to give everybody a thousand
dollars and people like remember the
first time you heard about your like
thousand dollars a month how can we
afford that and he said well here's well
maybe that makes sense he had a plan
that no one was talking about then
everybody started doing research that
brought a lot of publicity to him now
he's being a interviewed all over the
place because his topic resonated with a
certain audience so let me give you an
example here Obama is debating Hillary
there's a very special moment there the
moderator asks Obama
questions they say senator Obama you've
been accused of plagiarizing and using
other lines of other people they use in
their own debates in this state this
person used these lines and you used it
what do you think about the the people
that are saying you are plagiarizing
your message and it's not really you
you're using other people's message and
Obama got up and says look there's
really two lines that I used it was this
line and is this line and it was used by
this camp I can't pay manager whom I
trust told me to to the language of what
we want to do is this is what we want to
do and these are some of the things that
may want to talk but and I use the line
yes I did I did use the line but here's
what I want to do I hope this debate is
not going to get petty and we're gonna
talk about lines rather than policies
I'd might try to spend time on policies
and he starts going through listing his
policies brilliant he went to what
matters to the American people says
because American people want to be able
to figure out Papapa Papapa right
policies then Hillary you know what do
you think about this and she says well
you know Barack I can appreciate that
you have a very good way of speaking and
communicating to people you're a great
speaker but look if you're gonna go out
there and plagiarize it's not really
what you stand for it's just like being
Xerox you're a copy machine
she says that then Obama says that's not
what that is Hitler like it's a shot so
that moment people like she went for a
shot and he went for policies we know
who ends up winning right so if you're
gonna go a direction and get away from
weaknesses you have to be able to go
back and stick to policies a lot of
people don't know how to do that we'll
see who's gonna be able to do it at this
time six likability matters people like
Obama
they just did people like Bill Clinton
people like George Bush you know people
like to uh would he call it Reagan
people like some of these candidates
people like JFK now Trump his audience
likes him because he's tough that's
still a part of likability it's not like
because Trump's the guy that's not la
you know you don't just like Trump you
either love him or you hate him it's a
love-hate relationship right but the
people who like him they love him like
oh my gosh he stands up he's gonna go
against swamp he still has a high
likability score with the people in his
party and and and and it's and it's
increasing in certain areas and
decreasing in certain areas but
likability matters as well so when you
look at the candidates who's likable 7
debate approach dirty or clean you know
you look at the games like if people try
to play the game against Trump the way
Trump is playing it and you see I'm
gonna go after him the way he goes after
people but if it's not naturally part of
your approach you're gonna fail because
Trump has been Trump for 70 something
years he's been witty for 70 something
years he didn't take a book on master
class or go watch a video on YouTube
saying 20 steps to being witty you don't
learn how to be with it you either are
witty or you're not witty so if you try
to go at them with being witty you're
gonna lose just ask Rubio and Ted Cruz
they couldn't do it because it doesn't
work if you go at it with them that way
it's not you gotta go look I understand
you want to go this direction here's the
policies but look in reality look what's
happened in these three areas that you
haven't paid attention to let's focus to
policy so if I'm competing against him
I'm saying let's focus here American
people want to know this let's focus
here let's focus policies he's gonna be
confused but he's playing your game like
in sports if you're going against
somebody you want them to play your game
now you play their game you played their
game they've been playing their game
longer than you you're gonna lose make
them play your game we'll see if he's
gonna do that or not they're gonna do
that on number eight social media team
it's very important right now whichever
Canada's got a strong social media
team's gonna matter social media team is
so important today Obama has a strong
social media team Trump has an
incredibly strong social media team
quick videos quick edits creative ideas
videos you know video that gets six
million views 2 million views 8 million
views 3 million views the moment you
have a line boom put that up there don't
we have another one put that up there
social media team is gonna be
very very critical because you know my
more time at 88 Nixon went against JFK
and there was ain't a'no not 88 88 % of
TV's people had TVs in America 1960
versus 11 percent in 1950 social media
video oh my gosh did you hear what
Elizabeth Warren just said to trump oh
my goodness did you hear what Bernie
said did you hear what Biden just said
did you hear what because that's the
videos viral share share share share
social media team and a 9 is work ethic
when you look at Trump versus Hillary
Clinton Hillary Clinton did sixty three
rallies Trump did one hundred thirty two
rallies you can't compete with a hundred
thirty two rallies if you're only gonna
do 63 every time you saw President Trump
another Facebook live another Facebook
Club another Facebook like one Facebook
live Hillary another Facebook live
another Facebook live another Facebook
live one Hillary you can't compete with
those kinds of numbers and last but not
least is media here's the thing about
media you're not people say well
everybody on the left in the media is on
the left they are just so you know that
the only TV station that's on the right
is Fox News everybody else is on the
left every one of them is anti Trump let
me explain to what happens here
let me explain to what happens here so
one time I'm listening to this guy
Morning Joe okay
he works for MSNBC and he grew up
conservative but he went to a very
liberal school he made the most
incredible point he says I went to a
liberal school every time I brought up a
point to debate and I was against the
teacher 20 students would attack me and
the teacher always defended the 20
students makes sense because these
conservatives they're all liberal so the
teacher would say Larry's right Bobby's
right Jackie's right Joe how do you know
if you're right because the teachers
liberal because the school's liberal and
everybody else in class is pretty much
liberal right he said here's what ended
up happening every time the teacher
agreed with the students the students
didn't need to go do research to make
the arguments stronger because the
teacher already agreed but every time
they disagreed with me I had to go make
my argument stronger boom I got better
and debating they did not point all the
guys in the media they get up and say if
Oh bite on one bug it went against today
they would win 56% over Trump what they
don't realize is when you put as if
Biden or Warren or Sanders already has
an edge against Trump you know what your
let me explain to you what this media is
doing you make Democrats not come out to
vote
you make liberals not come out to vote
and conservatives watch this on CNN or
MSNBC or ABC or and it's oh my gosh
we're behind guys guys get everybody get
everybody go vote so what media doesn't
know is even though they're gonna be Pro
whoever on the Left they're gonna hurt
the left because all they do is defend
the left and voters don't come out
because they think it's already done big
if I'm if I'm the chairman of either one
of those political side I'm calling
media saying stop saying we're ahead
stop saying we're ahead guys are not
coming out you got to say we're behind
because the person that's gonna wonder
2020 election is the underdog Trump was
the underdog what about what was the
underdog last two presidents the
underdog is one hey the underdog is
winning go last four presidents Bill
Clinton was underdog George which was
underdog the underdogs are last four
president if the media wants to help
seeing who wins the next election you
better produce an underdog mentality if
you do you have a shot if you don't your
next president in 2020 is gonna be
Donald Trump again so now these are my
thoughts here's what you have history
these are the issues you got the ten
things that I'm sharing on what needs to
happen and 2020 to see if there's gonna
be a fight for who's gonna be our next
president in the United States if you
want to get the PDF of today's episode
and you're in the United States with
you're in u.s. you can text this number
three one zero three four zero one one
three two three one zero three four zero
one one three to text us and type in
2020 election notes we'll send you back
the PDF you can take a look at and do
whatever you want to do with it if you
want to watch a couple of other videos
that have to do what I talked about
there's one video that I just produced
it's the u.s. Iran relationship history
of u.s. Iran relationship the thumbnail
is here click here to watch it and if
you've been kind of following some of
the stuff that's going on with 5g
us-china trade war if you still haven't
watched you as China trade where I'm
going to put that video here as well
this is an old one if you watch it go
watch Iran one if you haven't yet but I
do if you want to watch both of them
click on them here and if you haven't
subscribed to the channel please do so
wanna hear your thoughts comment below
take everybody bye-bye
you